some new information has surfaced in the
world of elden ring lore that has me
feeling a bit creeped out to be honest
it has to do with the godskins and their
distaste towards the greater will we've
learned this new information from a
youtuber named daniel almost who took
the time to translate the godskin
apostle theme music from latin to
english and let me just say the results
have given me a different more haunting
outlook on the godskin characters as a
whole so go subscribe to daniel i'll
leave his channel link in the
description he's been translating music
by from software for a while now and i
think his work is vital in unraveling
hidden lore themes in elden ring so go
show him some love so in this video i'm
going to play segments of the music with
the english translations and we'll talk
about what these translations could mean
in regards to the lore also this video
is sponsored by you guys and your
generous support here on youtube and
patreon the extra support helps me
create sustainable content and allows me
the freedom to work on projects that
would otherwise be a bit risky to take
on going forward plus you get some extra
benefits like early access to all videos
without any ads and discussion threads
for all future content so thank you very
much to my patrons that you can see on
the screen make sure to like and
subscribe so my dog can keep getting
belly rubs and treats for every new
subscriber with all of that said let's
get into the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so what we know about the godskins is
that they once served the greater will
alongside the glomide queen as the
protectors and distributors of destined
death with the power of the black flame
and death and death in hand they could
kill nobles and gods alike who are
destined to die however some of these
followers would betray their posts as
guardians of destined death and would
abuse the power of the black flame it
would seem like because of this abuse of
power queen merica and the greater will
ordered malaketh to take destin death
away from the glomide queen and seal it
away inside of maliket's black blade
with the glomide queen defeated and
destined death taken away the power of
the black flame and its ability to slay
gods was gone now this first verse of
the song we just listened to shows us
that the godskins felt overshadowed by
the greater will and that they feel
their purpose and power was unrightfully
taken away from them so what they do to
combat this is to take the skin of those
who follow the grace of the greater will
this could be to gain some of their
power back or just a slight against the
greater will altogether
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i feel many people would interpret
the golden bloodline as all of the
demigods under queen america and the
greater will however i think it's more
accurately linked to godfrey and his
golden lineage such as his son godwin
and later down the line with god of roy
and then finally godric the grafted who
in our fight with him is constantly
mentioning the lord of all that is
golden and referencing back to their
home bathed in rays of gold i am the
lord
of all that is golden
and one
day we'll return together
to our home
bathed in rays of gold
this could also be referring to
godfrey's army of tarnished warriors who
were banished from the lands between
once their guidance of grace was taken
from them by queen america maybe this is
why godric uses the tarnished like the
tarnists who traveled from the lands
between with rodericka for his grafting
process it could be that he feels a
connection to them from his golden
lineage background to go along with this
and i'm sure most of us know this by now
the godskins apparel or their clothing
is actually made from the skin
of those they see as gods although it
doesn't seem like the skin they take is
always that of an actual god as we can
see a normal noble ghost begging for his
skin to not be taken
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so we can take from this final verse of
which in my opinion is the best ost in
all of elden ring is that the godskins
will hunt down those guided by grace
forever relentless in their pursuit of
the power that was taken from them long
ago and knowing this it makes a lot more
sense that we fight against the godskins
so many different times they are
relentlessly hunting us for our guidance
of grace and it's possible that the
godskins don't really know where
malakath is and where he has hidden
destined death and are potentially
tracking us throughout the lands between
in order to find it now this sort of
gets confusing because they attack us
multiple different times in many
different places on our journey so why
wouldn't they just fight us the one time
in pharaoh missoula once we're close to
malakath and the rune of death now this
is likely because they're trying to stop
us from uncovering other secrets that we
can find after defeating them in the
bottom of caled's divine tower we can
find an apostle guarding the godslayer's
greatsword which is a sword once used by
the glomide queen to control the
godskins and the power of the black
flame on the bridge to the carrion
divine tower we can find a godskin noble
who is likely guarding ronnie's
discarded body in one half of the curse
mark of death that we can find here as
well at the top of windmill village we
can find another apostle who is likely
just in this area to receive the skin
that the dancing ladies of windmill
village have skinned for the apostles
clothing next we can find a godskin
noble in volcano manor likely protecting
the serpent's a minion which is from a
mother's womb which cradled the poor
unwanted offspring of a repellent
birthing ritual now this could be in
reference to how the godskins are
actually born maybe how they're created
and why they have certain features that
resemble that of a serpent finally we
meet both the godskin noble and apostle
in pharah missoula likely to stop us
from taking the rune of death from
malakath so that they can do it
themselves and take back control of
destined death and restore the full
power of their black flame i made an
entire video on the gloamide queen and
destined death a little over a month ago
which goes over the theory that melania
is the gloam or dusk-eyed queen there's
still a solid amount of evidence that
supports this theory and is still what i
believe to be true obviously the largest
piece of evidence for this is during the
flame a frenzy ending where her eye
changes to a gloam color and swears that
she will deliver to us what we deserve
destined death i'm really curious of
what you guys all think about the
godskins and how they're linked to
destin death pretty much everything
we've talked about i would love to hear
your interpretation of the song and the
translation from latin to english i
really hope you guys enjoyed this video
i would call it more of a snapshot lore
hunting video than a fully flushed out
deep analysis obviously i will still be
working on those big projects along with
these snapshot lore hunting videos i
started the lore hunting series about
two months ago and it's what really
lifted my channel off of the ground so i
would like to do these videos every now
and then along with the deep analysis
lore videos so let me know what you
would all like to see next i'd like to
give another thank you to my patrons who
make videos like this possible and going
the extra mile to support my content in
the future of the channel thank you all
for watching and i'll see you in the
next video take care